أعد توجيهكم يا رفاق وهو طبق
لأولئك الذين يحبون زبدة
هداياهم ، قم بتليين الزبدة أثناء
ركوب قمة اتجاه الطهي ، هل
سمعت عن لوح الزبدة ، هل سمعت عن
لوح الزبد بالملل حرفيًا مملوءًا
بالزبدة ومن يدري ماذا  رش
عليها أطنان من الملح الرقيق أطنانًا من
نكهة الليمون وقليلًا من رقائق الفلفل الأحمر
والتين الطازج والفراولة وأضيف إليها بعض
الثوم المحمص.
جزء المشاركة الذي أذهل
هذا المشكك يبدو وكأنه لوح من
الجراثيم والغبار وشعر يتساقط فيه ، لكن
المؤثر في الطعام في Justine snacks
يطرح الاختلاف ، أنا أحب ذلك الفيديو الخاص بها ، على
الرغم من أنها
تنسب إلى Joshua McFadden الذي أدرج لوحة الزبدة
في كتابه لعام 2017  الآن هو ملك
للجميع ، هذا للموت من أجله أو
الموت بسبب رصيد واحد أطلقنا عليه اسم
كومة مقززة من الشريان التاجي عندما
لم يلتهمها هذا القراد تمامًا.
لماذا تمضغها
كما لو كانت قطعة علكة
، ينتقل البعض بالفعل إلى
لوح الجبن الكريمي المغطى بأقفال
ونبات الكبر الممسحة ببيغل بالفعل ،
بدأ لوح الزبدة في الشعور
وكأنه بيتزا محملة بقطع من
السلامي المقدد.  مربى المشمش تصادف أن
لدي هذه الزهور المجففة الصالحة للأكل ، لماذا فقط
زبدة الخبز الخاص بك عندما يمكن أن يكون
خبزك مغطى بالزبدة يا رفاق ، يتم تقديم هذا بشكل مثالي
مع خبز قاسي دافئ ،
وسرير قشري دافئ هو مقبلات كثيرة جدًا من
جينيموس سي إن إن نيويورك